there's no better feeling than solo
killing somebody and when you do it at
Worlds it's even more impressive so
here's our list of the best solo kills
from every single world so far starting
with this unforgettable reversal by SK
T's dukes they're down in the bottom
Lane showers lift the load he walks over
the minions side steps a deadly flourish
ml X G's looking for the kill
sonic wave connects resonating strike
dude what just survived
exactly and getting the doublet furball
drink is just enough to keep rocks in
the game Oh manners assassin he supports
what is it 2013 poke down c9 before they
fight here and since I've already been
through Coast she's gonna find two
players Duke's Megan off was used
earlier
loofa plus a tower not gonna be enough
to kill you but because he's getting
pushed it of you likes a hired spell
damage pull in old he doesn't do it for
a crowd kid here's your test papa
what's up pray take her on NL they're
just putting up a bit NL - except to try
and save himself but making a lot of
damage gonna come in for the kill very
stylish q but I think he's dead trying
to buy time good about getting to kill
here for these just about to counter
gank only support and then think it set
up the time but he's done he chose it
for himself much more quickly
that is opponent and this has to respect
that actually it's the trouble here
that's a lot Kira in trouble Bri needs
one more can me light it up there's a
bus that secure star kill bus blood
don't you see
Oh doesn't it flash says Porto smooth
it's the Ragnarok I'm gonna probably
force the flats not even up it's like
five seconds classroom coming up turret
going down Samsung Galaxy 4 to 3 in this
woman now and looper looking for the big
play on the cuvette gets the auto
attacks and that's what he was hoping
for all a long beard it took the rafters
away he's taking the drugs as well but
now it's a flashing gauge breaker he got
a blue buff back and Kuro stayed bid for
far too long a lot of damage dumped
we're gonna make the unveil the chase
[Applause]
Lincoln you have tanks on SKT you have
no tanks aren't you fill it to orangey
they slowly that cloud rate contestant
is about to car out throws looper
against the wall stuns it with the
wallop crunches down looks for more
white Blanco Juke solos loop back or
those build surveys going again he is
indeed Mouse will be up shortly
Thank You base got flash there we go
flash board male strip this makes it
look way too easy does go down so in the
end thank you so much trundle slicing
Maelstrom Steve's rep residence allows
wanted a runaway for DOJ delivers
ambitions but not gonna be needed puppy
let it bounce back to try and furnished
impact with the second and fishing
factor from the top lane
yeah do you think that a free push but
right now is in danger cube a first
blood gonna be at least one summer
blowing here but sweetie couples and the
question has been is the communication
there between smoothie and medius for
sure it was on that one crown moose fat
yes there's a petrifying gaze so they
get steak it down didn't think ambition
was gonna get there in time meteos just
on the eggs shockwave with the midlane
petrify flashes
[Applause]
kinda go back and get his own blue and
bengi so chooses this makes it difficult
for crap rookie arty burn some summer
spells and it's all turned out twice
just to shut off the wave my god the
shots but nobody dies up in the top lane
do you can q they ain't going toe to toe
slicing Maelstrom beds do they have the
right player good sized tip again that's
the second time this game is way
equalizer comes up saying X flashes for
the kill
how much will this hurt simulates that
will get one yeah he says for the
lawsuit he kind of got surprised the
bike overheating a little bit got a
little scared that was in the end come
here sit not again right under that much
that pop steel she's gonna walk into
range to get the revive or the hoe he's
not going to now buy our fresh shielded
him so huge miss play by Pearson flash
list Templar as well ghosts only better
be bold move here to chase and a solo
kill the mid lane at level 5 finish that
collapsed on sonic waves ward hop the
sonic wave connects shred scaring
follows him over the wall but mlx cheese
running a mile a minute energy out flash
forward sonic wave
it's Tara gets the kill now the retreat
because Bobby wants in on the doublelift
how's that duel gonna go josh is 1q look
so dodge the next one mark inside the
page he's coming back again there's the
gates yeah I'm looking for more is ballz
able to get a lot of damage through the
dock
flash is out of the way but it's not
enough balls is gonna sacrifice himself
zip 7 to 82 in that bomb so you're
taking a lot of down into there for some
time and apprehend comes in that's gonna
be a lot of damage to time he wants it
the all comes down but it's not enough
Oh interesting Lee of course with class
focus guys their base health is actually
quite low both do plenty damage early on
so it like it all in is palpable ooh the
damage you can see cheaper there's ago
see pops he's going after g4
he's got no flash
the Soul Stealer is a different thing
it's time for revenge the flash deployed
used right away oh there where does let
go right into a flame chart to flame
spinner flame effect was that RM
choppers would you see that waveclear be
so useful waste oh wow
he's decided to go aggressive causes
being caught out chum the waters goes up
in waste or incarnation may want to look
for zip he doesn't ever knock up charge
yet we'll need to follow up with the
steel tempest now it's got a little ball
level who will he hit cuz you have one
target exhaust is up jumps onto Albus to
close the distance incarnation stories
join the fighters wild zip is being
jumped on but HQ be happy with this tie
he's getting caught by sceeto
yeah rapid-fire means a lot there's the
rocket ship for it hexdrinker popped and
this could be enough yes sneaky it's
easy for barn to us out at open Anakin
the top side the match just belongs to
SK Telecom oh so much damage at bar
trying to chuck him down he's got a lot
of damage that's what a couple more
spells will do it there's the hill gonna
find him here and he's got level six
Kouros challenge to knee it's tough be
tough and jungle of each angle Rudy's
been propped
Korra's regen Rudy's gonna run away
Destiny's being channeled the dunk comes
down
bokura take the tower shut pause get to
kill and reignover
say especially around fighting topic
kappa hores going low enough information
maybe great chase continues but what's
gonna riffle goes by he might be able to
kill Featherman as he does would gets
one before reckless zaps him down
prepared for this match movement
therefore of a dull early game right now
amazing doll head away from maple wood
sleepy Prada pretzels sharpers did it
certainly anything but toll you're
amazing trying to run out maple put city
night w will kill him that ought to
litter egos pumping out a little bit
game has been snail as i say that we may
see some action no flash head but
pulverize comes in may
the massive outplay jumps back Jukes bit
me there's nothing else to do whereas
WordPad went 14
displaying only level three the dockets
come through he has flash he'll use it
if he needs to
it's the heal enough to trade one back
here the dragon
even if origin decided no hope he's got
him he's dead he's dead his dad there we
go
it looks funky looking for another
diamond ball more action down the
middling the duel continues incarnation
taking quite a bit still has that
barrier rookie needs to be aware he's
got his undertow back to the field gets
his son on to incarnation could be in
trouble again he pops a barrier
incarnation and rookie takes to 1v1 tool
incredibly though the Lee sin is snuck
behind who knee while is a two-on-two
Rhyno has joined the fight who he's
going to get the shield just dunks him
in the spot
Oh challenge time some day to be in a
bit of trouble slicing and dicing away
Kenosha to get there in time of the
cocoon smeb's gonna go in flash to chazy
only God the turret
he gets a heal some day gets taken down
it looks like spams gonna fake it out
plus the Caitlyn can take down almost
any turret oh here we go again step off
the sub day used to eat the Grand
Challenge and some day can't even
survive it through the ultimate now was
pushing that dyrus gets a big wave good
boy was down to something he got the way
from oh I say that was
a good decision Eriksson than the 1v1
admit the world oh man
dyrus blacked up on the wall by the
condemned gets taken down by if you can
even get your members to join in half at
5.30
I think the Black Cleaver is giving him
the move speed and that's a dead so s
great buy on the Merc treads in order to
hear it worthy of that and now faker is
in so as has no chance getting away
hexdrinker
you barely even saw it slice and dice is
available for Maura
then they get the stun on to on and
slices and dices away on the follow with
the rocket jump Baker kill zip on the
backline lashes he concludes him
afterwards - he gets low enough that
they can kill him during the cocoon
iteration and we have some wow it's
gonna get killed
we're still follows the flash
[Applause]
teleport available for sim five Chum the
waters and Baker will not be able to get
out u.s. stall point us kth do with the
D ports the bottom aren gonna go all in
let's take a look level 52 level 13 sips
gonna be able to prop the Grand
Challenge noxian life will not even get
activated GQ with all the poke they
tried to do down on the turret will
branch out is up now oh dear Oh warlock
take it out pretty good then this port
in our top lane right down bit later it
also goes down the flashing gate from
Baker and as the rune prison in it all
the spells all of the time fake the 1v1
again spawn it's caught up figure how
wants to kill for oh what a turn maker
pressuring Kuro here flashes and gets
the kill escaped he remind you of right
now it teams down holding out with some
nice team I was gonna say pop verrano's
like this game is brewing
smeb bring it out to plays he
a bit more to offer he has just taken
the turret with happiness a smile on his
face a few more
everyone had to do the right thing to
avoid dying there which is a little bit
dangerous slashes were blown in the mid
lane as well looks like
Baker and Kuro went hard so there's no
flash for this Oh
in a real bad situation with the last
bit of mana and he's sitting at baseball
he's quit TV somewhere he's great now
is going to the river brush but his jaw
dropped immediately how did he even
think he could take that fight didn't
see the laser come out first
[Music]
ahran he got the ulti Pop's it so I was
gonna be in a bad way - and it's gonna
be a flash follows only one vital left
and Martin can't quite reach it but it
gets too slow but it's enough to get
Martin to kill anyway turn citizen all
right Bernie's gonna pick a fight once
more with Smith and Grand Challenge
throws down Smith Sascha's away from the
third crook of the broken wings Rooney
so when we've been hurt here so smelly
let's see what happens all right let's
throw everything and the sink at Smith
he's already chunked who knee down the
play comes out let's got one and he's
not done he's looking for yellow star a
Nova reign over and borrows the rest of
remember back in 2011 when solo killing
someone was as simple as pressing three
buttons
well here's TSM's Reginald doing just
that in this next play this could be a
very very dead Annie say this is going
for here they got there's a class and
the oh here comes tons of damage up on
flash goes out but it was one each still
picked up great play there on both sides
blah me is still hanging around there
though and we are gonna see a little bit
of ice we kick it off the middle losing
night on Selina is he going to survive
20 help good flashing from Shushi and
that will be the kill moment just our
Braves that doing lots of work he is too
and Oh 37 minions we could see Tonka
last hits on all sides that you thought
gonna push he got into that turn taken a
lot of damage out there and the body
slam oh it's gonna be close and there's
vero he's not gonna quit Lana but he
jumped right back in there picking up
that killed great play by so as there is
a gank incoming uh-oh look so much
damage the ultimate Oh
just as I said there's a beautiful first
button that run block yes this is my
ruffle it's so powerful
Tarek returning from base with a heart
of gold and I'm sorry 1001 let's see if
you can do enough let me show you this
press yes and with the wonderful bandit
trust there the long game
a little speck while the damage that
said that I can lead us to chop ya jus
at least going wow wow that is West rice
on his game right there I'm sure that
you know if xpeke was playing this this
way and it would look quite different
but but we laugh we have indeed in West
rice that might have been a little bit
optimistic of you there yeah oh yeah I
think that should be a that I Cali final
row isn't wow that was close
oh wow if you had not used his ultimate
that you would have been there
oh and you know look at that he's going
right back oh wow oh this is bad news
for who all this is bad Oh No yes can
you gonna kill now he has the slowdown
on I mean where that I moved flashes
away oh and he flashed up Amy really
wants that first one Meredith is a dad
should be first block and double bars
for team fnatic I guess he feels safe
the jugglers might be far but always
gonna go red for the cursor
I've been gonna take an exhaust for the
face and lay waste to the beef Westar is
gonna chop in any way on the pika hindi
dude up there is the ultimate is flop
one more attack he might pick up a kill
and gets gonna trouble I picked one up
really neither the turn no he will not
present will channel is ultimate bliss
rice with a lot
Rock a great counter pick indefinitely
using their skills their advantage and
there's high tier play able to do some
escapes a very nice job with the
ultimate it looks like he could do a bit
of damage will he be able to take them
down going for the transfusion and he
does very nice then we see that it
almost written pretty much cancel his
ultimate looks like there comes the gank
from Alistar up at the top Rainman
probably not gonna do tunes actually
playing aggressively because he thinks
he's alright and mr. feint will he jump
in no case I'm gonna still just run
around solo and rake not in a good place
there comes Cassatt and finally rake
looks like he'll make it out and now the
rain man's gonna be chased down
can they get enough done with this oh
he's diving into the turret really gonna
fling off in time he's been silenced
rate can you get away can you get away
can you get away nope bling he's you've
gotten that kill there's the guilty
and they both
[Music]
let's take any any damage with me today
oh yeah how to kill you before you kill
without this yeah that was just enough
them astray Wow delusion from behind the
dust bringers out so he has the speed
you're on to die here's the 3d one but
the counter game won't be in the turn is
right man he could turn this around
shine comes out with a kill in a 3d one
situation to run out now in pursuit it's
gonna be illusion but they completely
back off Templar usually the force right
now for this parameter property so free
Wow room going down very low gear this
manner just about the same but the HP is
not magic really getting sucked down EDD
taking it down in a one-on-one or rather
Reginald is the chase right now from
shine the flash over and he's just gonna
walk through the file happily the
exhaust goes down that single target
damage is going to be a lot of first and
rational just really trying to do it he
can't before going down but biding time
for team his team to do other things
requiem conscious John and he does go
die though one foot wide a puppy ebdb
spidey-sense diamond being around but he
did retreat this mid lane actually is
pretty difficult for Alex this is really
what happens though is like I said the
Cassiopeia but if it kind of exciting
end of the turn ignite is on as well
this could be enough it is seat I pick
up the second kill of the patch
we pray now just picked it up Oh gotta
be careful of Quebec dunno survival safe
he's got all and ghost trying to get
away from this one there's this Whitsett
about something dog up they're gonna get
the damage province is waiting in the
wings it's gonna realize that dark
binding comes it because that way
snooping take it now very low he's gonna
back off there snooping goes down to the
ignite and the poison from shine and now
wicked is in trouble
shine to the wanted and he's not able to
tell him again about a game coming up
Harper's lookit he's a traitor when I
want to be one wing Keegan's I want this
to be the capital T is gonna do enough
damage all tall skinny be soon we can
just feel it
the vial I think that has to separate
themselves with Marcus here he does a
great job in five ten bucks just on the
outside dude this stars offshoot of
jumps Ben they're getting kind of change
the way but look at that slow the
undertone so perfect right there he
starts building out damage but watch all
walks back in and he wasn't ready for it
dodging good counter attack damage
really really high
we'll be there with actually Alex in bad
safe yourself a present of the tie he's
gonna turn that one back ignite will
pick up that kill wind on Alex at this
point the GDD again down bottom he's
finding himself in a bad situation he
came out with a girl on this before
it did not go down but it does not look
like he has the help from his teammates
he may play Go Go Votto
Darien is very close and he does come
out with him he was kicked away but
dragons legs
he could easily sustain himself back up
here King toys here in the jungle this
could be good for boys not really
catching him they're huge damage coming
out from Alex is really flashed over for
the kill and it looks like he may be
able to get LANDesk you out you lands it
amount of power really Alling them the
Alexei's coming in huge right here on
the top turn it has been prepped to be
taken down but it's focus is only
Stanley coming up with the kill the
sucker in there just whoops the pull
back over toys like seed Ronnie got
aggressive on rapid style here how's it
going up to finish mommy boy
[Applause]
Oh big fight down by we shout hi Paulo
playing we shall divert towards elephant
he's got now to it and he gonna beat
realize easy the goose is cooked
weasels gonna take it down and of course
they're gonna go in there wicked versus
Chow Mei don't wear way there I think
Charlie's got around really careful he's
gonna be very careful with this won't be
able to get away could come out could
get a full deck walk there from
Charlie's just about it range if you
balance is it no he's gonna bait him it
said keep trying get towards the top
you're gonna go down and that's a
straight walk he won exchange Chow mate
once the mid lane meta shifted to the
assassin meta it allowed the game's best
players to make huge individual plays so
first off here's the iconic 1v1 between
Reginald and faker faker actually tuned
down a lot of damage vegetal curse
aggressive weasel to it Oh down but it
is gonna be high going aggressive urchin
strike is available on spec a you can
see these already use that night good
take it very low my god get this one
first but by chewing it happens so
incredibly quickly meanwhile panicking
here I'm so Alex in that mid lane
commands will take comes down but
Peggy's going for this one it's gonna
flash it okay we'll pick up the kill
gender tell me is it you're working just
gonna flash it will go down anyway
pulling off those paradise because she
can drop tower aggro but you'd even have
to bring up all the flash to the pollen
he gets the kill on mass or an amazing
play by nuke duck there that singular
ward in that river manages to give
himself a hill and the turret the tarpon
is gonna be to the detriment of
ex-special
XO landing every skill shot he needs to
now all of a sudden alex is in trouble
I should pick this one up use my manages
to land that this is break any car on
top of a ward Baker's gonna walk in
let's thank you very much for the free
kill I'm gonna kill you and every Lane
is getting punished for oil right now
because godlike cannot push up against
impact and Baker took away watch pretty
good trade doing dragon for just one
kill but they all go watch mid power
fakers in trouble there that was a gonna
throw down a barrel that explodes that's
two kills now the sword yeah let's watch
that to get Baker he was able to dodge
so look at the side step from to
expecting that Baker then he just burst
him down
and there's the dart sphere at the asite
tip was auto attack his mini Kingston
and he was like impact codes heart they
throw it in the equalizer but he has the
chance to instantly walk out of him me
turn it into a 2v1 kill he goes on the
cod leg he gets the flask
the Empowered goes out but lucky gonna
continue to chase look he might get the
skill here comes world turtle Bray Bray
going Japanese no gonna be enough
no just the couch that's right that's
gonna be one kill em fight goes down
there's gonna be candy get on the walls
you know he's gonna be busy
[Applause]
the poison takes five people right now
he actually goes in try to get it
together get a kill on his fire over the
pot welcome once the wall down we'll all
Teodor Luther look at that timing bull
comes in from Daris he sidesteps oh wow
even finish it off they kill there in
the end to neuter zero zero good watch
he's just gonna get melted Baker's got
another spur rush is gonna get bored
picks himself up the kill just melts
watching the jungle Q coming back in the
sand equalizer across inside our team
and we are gonna see now the damage he
does and he goes back to his shadow
going company nosy though gonna try to
push it back him on the heel will get
all the help
[Applause]
the girl decent 8 people walking in in
level 3 there's 30 deputies the flash
comes around the side
the tanker prolly ill there is a room
so they have a kale ulti though by and
I'm not sure it's gonna work out too
well for pry these gonna get down Oh
coral here though he might not stay calm
westdoor going for it he's gonna go in
now the question is uh nothing he's got
the damage to finish
this is so unfortunate - holy Phoenix
being on some of his favorite champions
but not being able to get resets he knew
that aah kook was gonna stay at the
tower keep the pressure going walks in
we always like that oh yeah where'd you
there's no cop
you got a quote yep get themselves a
nice bear in a tent oh my gosh on to
west door oh definitely gonna have to be
a better lane match up if they want that
faceoff to go any better Jack and Freud
left if no reach to slow down let's see
what happens in mid lane there's a bit
of a hit morning not really winning this
fight though the Ignite goes down to
both sides he pulls the ball to him
perfect move by cord to deliver it back
out he's not able to finish off kills
he's going in damage I felt that oh boy
more often than not
dyrus has been getting himself into some
1t1 situations they gonna lose
brutalizer it's all about fighting fight
set mark going down what is he gonna be
enough Sonny is gonna be
my coffee they want to see that
interception of da de so they actually
turns back around and Peggy's the one
that goes for it
he oats first Wow so that's the thing
about da days build right now he has an
infinity-edge tunnel and channeled all
their farm into pecking and reckless oh
not a bad choice what reckless is this
strong evolution bf sword and to bog
swords this early Jesus scary dude why
is the cooling from reckless there is
the - in one moral doing and the danger
I think that I think you now have is yes
they're gonna try and sit on those
inhibit two turrets and try and get
involved a showers down so us gonna get
off heads ahead and there is equalizer
coming down and so it says you know what
I kind of fancy this one he's gonna get
all the way in the last second foot
there's a clean City Council but it
hasn't come top tower also did not go
down by the way go going shockwave
pulled on towards cool flash goes here
we will is there sure what my basic
attack there's the ignite maybe didn't
actually see oh oh see oh yeah let's
listen here there where where
he's not available the answer squad
coming in here shook and froggit trying
to make things work they have split the
fight now they won't both pass through
it's gonna be a few hits each night Oh
Chum the water is gonna eat that one up
very nice NIT Luke's come leaping lost
in this game right let's see a front
good new Broadway gonna go towards that
pass he got the damage lems gonna try
and turn it around but he's only got
that captain is completing no rod of
ages just yet while froggen past machine
broke it off he should open up one boy
will do it they're gonna try and push
off me as quick as possible Alliance
have to swing around and sweep with
trying cause this one slow slow
chokehold bullfrog in here step it up a
little bit showing the waters comes out
dance quickly stepping out are always
gonna come on kill Bruce up flashes to
land the trickster heart it blaze hits
what he's gonna moving look at least
froggen wills for high ready--catch gets
the slower too hard to go the damage to
finish up storm comes right from high
I'm not sure change this one around is
Lee just having to jump away as well
meanwhile high is backed away onto the
red the water they come out
203 know instead of tsunami instead but
you use that shockwave that they've
saved before he's probably going to go
down will he take more exciting Oh
trouble though he's gonna face a crisis
bird that there's the kick coming in and
well he could do a full skirt against
these wraps hate holds your awards
however so what we would admit late the
trickster back down is the flashes do
this on you walk say up to the
Mackenzies only gonna roll the base they
don't think is defensively it up he's
gonna follow through one way to do it
the pop goes through ignite is running
there's the kill
can he get away though I want oh it too
many oh are they gonna be okay danger
daddy's [ __ ] real danger Dada is big in
Mexico
dandy they need to get out puller hit
the heart it's gonna be up for a little
bit there's the twisted advance arcane
smash and it's gonna come through for
the Cal they will make up no blooper
hence the auto attack from the world oh
is it leave Joe hanging again we got
work out this triple triple band cast
here
Oh fries instead yeah yeah I have to say
just the way that Samsung wife played
that fight as well
I mean pod went and took the cue from
crystal so that Tandy survived for that
as well I don't know there's flash up
for loop right what's a couple more hits
and then Freddie now tower diving on
there he's gonna get paid oh he's in
trouble he gets caught up in it the
return go that edge though to TPA
because it was GSM we spent the extra
time on Dragon and the mid laner who got
first but but if it gives her right back
oh really locked it down now move it in
so those wolves earlier on it's Gilo
coming down into the middle ultimate
from Genesis well
you just have to give up at that point
the teleport was completely wasted TSM
had a monsters of there's no escape and
SK just make matters worse Wow
Julius going down cheston's in the wrong
place at the wrong time and the cow
is that this game of battery as well :
actually going to go in Christ if he
rocks or Spears if death marks gonna be
used but only Fuchs is gonna come on top
of this one cooler just simply kills him
with one on one sometimes always sending
a little bit magnificent job before the
map but it's also watch with the site
zone is the one for twine somebody he's
gonna be the death part but ignite he's
down as well so he can stay out on the
map longer and had still have worked
yeah same is gonna just turn around and
kill me tails throwing spank me so hard
the cloud Knights wisely walk away and
paintball other he's gonna get a support
from walls here but save just gonna blow
to beaches take down that's gonna be
Cola he gets shut down goat their paws
not done in the middle play bike or
pretty beneficial for him in this game
but honestly it's about cornsnake save
him it's a little dangerous for him to
open up he actually opened up as if he
had backup corn decided not to turn he
realizes the bat resistance has been
built oh now they buzzes if it's a water
one but it's gonna be now ain't going
can he get away takes tower hits doesn't
buddy I think he realized he was going
down there yeah Oh inferences
- v1f czf first possibly no clearlove
he's gonna drop in there dot DS out of
the bubble there's one losing back to
the second nose just gonna back away he
can still click it when it just becomes
even harder or if it's in mid lane that
gate turns it back around on cool air
tries to put the pressure on him turns
around with a double aparts down to the
background ignite doesn't matter cuz
ball has his ulti everyone piles through
and cloud nine just cannot get the upper
hand at the start of a fight we're
seeing how important blue side first
biggest in this matchup of these two
kids with it you know speaking on for
the duel oh you got the blue bow player
as well the bat yeah alright so here's
the door once again good job mark
already used so that's why Donna's gonna
go all the way in here the think was to
mediate shot mate spigot what a hero
he's gonna die free me this is surely so
much gonna go down but he's putting in
some decent damage big night will be
used but the one with pressure on
actually court the one with pressure on
himself right now able to playful and
trickster over the wall dodging quite a
bit out here throws to Chum the waters
on to clearlove and he gets out safely
what are you doing corn trying to go off
now he paints down clearlove he's so
happy to go one for one in any of these
engages cannot really go in there it's
our thing keeps our body
not a damn it's a lot of snick potential
as well glass coming in actually the
stick potential comes out the cut pod
can hit the cue is over and over again
it would be a very dangerous route to
steal the jagged good flash good flash
counts a flash holy Phoenix trying to
win it how's it gonna come in trouble
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]